let's go to the phone lines at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 starting today with our caller
from the 907 area code who's calling
today from 9 1 7 hey David this is
Sebastian how are you good how are you
good good good
so I live in Poland and I was gonna look
look at your twitch channel to watch the
debate from yesterday and it seems like
it's been blocked and I'm not sure if
you're aware of it Oh believe me I am
aware bastion so what happened is that
the the our channel our stream and
channel were taken down by someone
claiming to represent CBS which
broadcasts the debate and this happened
as far as we can tell exclusively to
left-wing streamers at the exact same
time the email address listed for this
company called praxis legal who did the
takedown bounces back it's a fake email
the website for this company has just
disappeared from the internet and there
is a legal investigation happening as we
speak being conducted by twitch legal
and attorneys that I've retained into
whether these are legitimate claims and
yes it we are in the middle of a mess
right now with regard to that right ok
ok I just wanted to see I wanted to send
you a message on Twitter but I don't
have an account on Twitter oh yeah no we
know we know that we did an entire story
on the show about it and it's a mess and
when we have resolution I will come to
the audience and say we figured out what
happened I think's been good job with
the program alright enjoy so much
Sebastian appreciate hearing from you
sebastian from poland let me make it we
definitely want in our notes that
sebastian is in poland